có phòng và kết địa phương được ra không bố không khai vùng khu của cầm bay,
tăng cường của nguyên kia tất cả sự nghiên cứu,
chứ kế sản xuất của bây trông nước.
Điều xử dụng bây phải được phản lý giám sát thông qua tất cả phương tệ và người được hiện.
Các tổ chức cả nhân sở hiệu bây phải khai báo,
chính phủ đặc mục tiêu đến năm 2018,
toàn bộ của bây trông nước được định dành số các phép địa tự và giám sát hành trình theo phy giám thật.
Cái yêu cầu trên được gương ra sau 20 cố liên thiết,
anh hưởng họn động khai thác tại sân bay tần sân nhất.
Tổng em muốn thăm hai được 2 bây họn động trải phép được phát hiện trong vùng trời của
li quả xân bay tần sân nhất,
sân bay phải tạm dương có thả cạnh hơn hai giờ khiến hạn loạt sân bay đến và đi phải thay đủ
lịch trình.
Mà ngày sau, vá người thật dự sau,
gắn lên chốt lên đổ cao khoảng 4 mẹ,
sân nhập thành lặng an toàn sân bay tần sân nhất khiến hành mốt sân bay bị anh hưởng.